i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle live once again from arizona
tonight
we're just four days away from the
critical midterm elections
and there are really two things that
currently hang in the balance an economy
as evidenced by today's job reports it's
roaring my friends and an immigration
policy
that makes sense and my simple message
is this
let's not stop success america since
we're here in the grand canyon state we
thought it was really important
to talk to some of the voters here so
i'm talking about people have
different political affiliations
different races different walks of life
to hear firsthand what really matters
most to them
ahead of tuesday's elections now these
are the voters who are going to decide
the neck and neck arizona race now
between martha mcsally republican
and the democrat kirsten cinema we're
going to talk to mcsally just ahead but
first
we wanted to hear from the voters
themselves we started this evening with
the pressing issue of immigration
and how illegals have affected this
border state
raymond arroyo joined me for the
questioning of this group
here's part one i want to begin with an
issue that is front and center right now
and that's the issue of immigration now
there are multiple caravans barreling
toward our southern border and as a
border state here in arizona
a lot of the migrants could end up in
your own backyard so
show of hands here how many of you think
we should welcome
all members of the caravan despite
evidence that there are criminals
within the group raise your hand
all members of the caravan oh i don't
think there's criminals
in the group you don't think there are
any criminals no i don't think there's
any crime i think there are
women and children who are
trying to get away from fear and
military dictators and all kinds of
other problems in their countries
and they're looking uh actually griff
jenkins
uh was our correspondent down and he's
been with the caravan for a number of
days
he interviewed various members of the
caravan and this is what he found
out on sunday let's watch are you
willing to break the law
to get back to the united states
he says he wants to apply for pardon for
the felony he committed
can you ask him exactly what happened um
number three a third degree felony
attempt of murder dan your reaction my
reaction is that uh
most of these women and children and
families are coming here for asylum
and they're doing it the right way they
you have to go to a port of entry
you have to turn yourself in at a poor
entry and you have to apply
for asylum now if they don't fit asylum
then they have to go back but if they
meet the criteria for asylum
they're not breaking the law they should
be inter letting now let's listen to
what president trump has to say about
the way
women feel about this caravan i don't
want them in our country
and women don't want them in our country
women want security
men don't want them in our country but
the women do not want them women want
security terri i saw you nodding your
head or shaking your head a minute ago i
don't care
if nobody is a criminal have some
respect for this country and do it
the legal way i'm a lifelong democrat i
switched over for trump
just to vote for him i've always felt
this way if we let these people come in
this way it's going to set a president's
they're suffering everywhere in the
world
where do we draw the line charity starts
at home let's take care of our own
first and foremost then we do it the
legal way
not illegally laura i see roy sitting
next to terry
champing at the bit go ahead roy i mean
to hear trump say that women don't want
the care van to come in i'm sure a
number of women wouldn't want to be
around
donald trump but first and foremost i
would say that that
you know let's go through the process
let's process uh each
uh case case by case if there was a
proper system
of immigration in place then we could
properly vet
those that were trying to enter into the
country
and decipher who was a criminal and who
was seeking asylum
julia you wanted to say what yeah there
is a
system how to come to this country i am
an immigrant
and i did it the right way you file your
paperwork
you get approved you come here it's as
simple as that well here's the here's
the problem is that
right now our system is being gamed
that's what a lot of people view that
the asylum system it's a good thing to
allow people to come in for asylum
for certain credible uh fears fear of
religious persecution
fear of ethnic cleansing uh true fears
of persecution for
uh you know political outlook but what's
happening for most of these migrants and
we had the mexican ambassador and the
guatemalan interior
minister on the other night on on the
angle and they both said
that most of these migrants
overwhelmingly they're economic
they're coming because like hundreds of
millions of people around the world
america is a great place to live and
it's better than most countries in the
world
and so they want to come there let's
let's go to sergio
laura i want to you know what the media
isn't also showing is that
they're passing live feeds of what's
happening in mexico
with this caravan and the caravan is
assaulting police officers and they're
throwing rocks and they're leaving trash
and they're tearing apart the country of
mexico you have people there
the own mexican residents that are
living there that are saying go back to
your country stop tearing apart ours
but there was also a feed of them
partying and having a good time and
being welcomed in different parts of the
community but they're taking this
mindset and they're coming and they're
bringing it down to this border
yvonne and on the top there i'm an
immigrant to this country
and i came here legally it took me 10
years to get my citizenship
and i also worked in the healthcare
industry and
you know they look at this caravan this
is an organized group
i really feel it's an invasion of our
country i mean
this is an organized caravan they have
people that have
have trucks are hauling these people on
the freeway
you know and then they look at the
caravan they're finding that
80 of it are men and less than 20
percent
are women and children yeah the again
the the the officials that are
monitoring this the mexican
uh officials the guatemalan officials
both that we've talked to
and that we've interviewed have
confirmed that they're overwhelmingly
able-bodied working-age men women and
children
being put in the front and the the
description of one
from one of the officials was almost
like a human shield
that that that's a fact that's not a
political opinion no matter what people
think about immigration
that's fine but it's not a political
opinion that's a fact and i have a
question how many of you here and you're
all of different
backgrounds and political persuasions
object to the use of the word
invasion raise your hand of course
so that's about half about split how
many of the people who object to the use
of the word
invasion are democrats raise your hand
uh they're coming here with their own
flag flying their own
flag they drew a swastika on the
american flag and burned it in front of
the honduran first
it's an invasion i'm sorry it's an
interface
all right back row hold on hold on we
got to give everybody everybody a
viewpoint here so in terms of it being
organized how is that different than
uh caravans of boats that came over uh
with what we call pilgrims which were
simply european refugees how is that
any different when we're we're talking
about uh caravans and
invasions but we're not talking about
what is the original in in the in
the invasion of this of where we sit
we are on invaded land that we invaded
well not
not i not i right but uh definitely
folks who didn't look like me
invaded this land well i think how many
here
believe that in part these caravans
have a political motivation and their
organization raise your hand
aren't they suing they just certainly
we're going to get to that let's let's
remember everybody has to get god wanted
to say something here clyde i just
wanted to mention
hearken back to what you said regarding
gaming the system and what that
gentleman said is probably true we've
been gaming the system ever since we uh
arrived by the mayflower that's why i
believe we have laws and that's why i
think we have a system
i think we do need comprehensive
immigration i got here in 1969 i've been
hearing the same story over and over and
over again
so i think that we need to take the rule
of law we need to enforce it
and when you said welcome i'm not sure
what that means we're a welcoming
country that can vet
each and every individual and use the
power of the united states of america
to keep us the united states of america
there was an important thing we learned
at the very beginning
this is a half republican half democrat
group only one person
said they wanted to welcome that caravan
it's very interesting the way these
arizona voters are breaking down this is
similar to what i found
when we were in texas last week very
similar now as you know
president trump has moved or vowed to
move 15 000
troops to the border i already moved the
initial uh to texas the texas border
which is where most of the
uh of these migrants will arrive uh
within the next month and president
obama is now responding
we want to play this for you get your
reaction watch they're even
taking our brave troops away from their
families
for a political stuck at the border
and the men and women of our military
deserve better than that
is this a political stunt in your mind
raise your hand
raise your hand if you believe there's
no reason to have the u.s military at a
border and it's purely politics
it is political all right hold on we got
to give everybody here a voice
yes sir yeah it is purely politics and i
believe this rhetoric is dangerous
when i go back to the word invasion we
are the greatest country in the entire
world
and we are scared of of a caravan full
of folks who are coming to seek asylum
i feel that we can have better use of
our troops time
and resources here in arizona at any
given time where i live in my community
we have over 500 homeless youth
one in four children go hungry i don't
feel this is a great way to utilize
our our nation's resources um and so
again we have to be very very careful
when we use the word
invasion i don't see this as an invasion
how many people uh
here are aware of the percentage of
drugs coming into the country
that come through arizona let's have
some guesses
what percentage of drugs come through
arizona 60
six bingo
40 of the drugs coming into the country
come through our southern border
the poorest nature of our border but i
also trust the current law enforcement
officials we have and i don't feel that
they need babysitters we have thousands
of border patrol agents
i have another question for the crowd
and then we got to move on to another
topic another question for the crowd
okay here's another question
do you prefer our military to enforce
the borders
of other countries which they're doing
in syria
and iraq on afghanistan and mostly in
the middle east
or enforcing if necessary the borders
of the united states first question
do you want the military enforcing the
borders of other countries
or the border of the united states let's
go to
uh totally okay with the military um
protecting our borders provided that we
were being attacked
i feel like that the nation is in
crippled in fear right now in each party
and sorry
um everybody is like just polarized
because
everybody's either bad or everybody's
good and there's no in the middle like
um regardless of the caravan there's a
lot of people who are
at the border already who walked
whatever that are really seeking asylum
so we can't lump everybody does asylum
seeking a job in the united states is
that asylum
but if that's what most of the people at
the caravan want
yeah i believe the caravans are like
probably a little different but the
no that's not actually not the caravan
is overwhelmingly
the caravan according to dhs
according to the mexican and guatemalan
officials
there's a lot of great people a lot of
great people there but overwhelmingly
when you
when they're interviewed overwhelmingly
before their you know their coach
they're interviewed
they're set they they want to work right
right and or they want their family
members are here
i mean and i think a lot of people
understand that it's very different from
a systematic ethnic cleansing systematic
uh persecution the christians in the
middle east are being beheaded buried
alive with their heads that's a
different type of situation
so we've got to be careful with our
terminology another issue which is
is nation gripped right now is the issue
of race
i want to play for this group all of
your different backgrounds
what is being said lately about
president trump let's watch
the president's obviously a racist he's
obviously a demagogue the rhetoric of
this racist
heartless soulless man will lead to more
violence yes i said that and a lot of
americans believe it too
it's a naked appeal to fear
and hate is what it is and it is racist
the president has always used fear to
his advantage
show of hands how many people think
those media appraisals
are accurate one two three four
who feels they're unfair
why julia i don't see
the president as a person that is a
racist he has shown that he has had many
people off
different backgrounds ethnic everything
and i don't think race is the issue it
is i don't like you i don't care
because what did i do
because who you are it's it doesn't
matter of your background whether you
were english german
white asian it doesn't matter it's
constantly used to make this man look
bad
use something different try something
new how many people here believe
that the charge of racism
is used to casually in the united states
raise your hand
um why
collide well i just think that what
you're seeing is the last gasp of a
desperate
a desperate group that needs that needs
votes because that's all the democrats
have
and you notice they're very quiet about
louis farrakhan and i went to the same
school as he did in boston know quite a
lot about that gentleman
and nothing is said about the things
that he has said such as
jews being termites and going back i'm
sorry going back to the original
uh time that he first got started so i
would say that they're just using that
and i'm not
seeing that and yes we've got a
president that's kind of a newbie
about being a president and he is
himself and he's a human being
but i would say that they're just using
this as race baiting and race and if you
crack a history book
you would see who very surely is the
person who uh has got us into many of
these situations
concerning race with uh african
americans you crack a history book
you'll see that there was 287 years of
slavery
based on race it wasn't based on
anything else
by the democrats and and propagated by
the democrats
from day one race we're not talking
about the 13th 14th and 15th
i let everybody talk can i make my point
yeah we're talking about based on race
african americans have been enslaved
african-americans after slavery after
1865
was subjugated to 100 years of jim crow
lynching disenfranchisement based on
race
so don't say that that the only people
that are playing
race identity politics have no merit
there's a huge merit no no there's a
huge
marriage okay well she hasn't spoken
about also the jewish community too you
cannot i'm not talking about
i don't know she asked a specific
question we're talking about race laura
specifically okay let's give her a
chance a response she asked a specific
question about whether
trump and everybody is he racist he's
not
it is an excuse there's no proof there's
no background do you know
what let's just let one person speak
guys my good friend marion mendoza knows
him and i know yes absolutely
don't
okay one at a time okay guys economic
opportunity in the united states
um we're gonna get into this uh what's
happened economically
and whether that has an effect in making
people see things maybe a little bit
differently
especially latino communities
african-american communities
asian communities and how prosperity is
rising across the board